right like you don't want to be taking somebody who has that kind of talent and is struggling
and then abusing that like their time and their energy and stuff and not giving them money even
if it's a small amount of money that's going to change their life right like give them the 150
or whatever that that you were gonna spend on team lunch or whatever the fuck and like you know
like change somebody's life instead of having a vdp yeah that's my call to action
hey everyone we've all heard of project discovery right the authors of nuclei h2px and countless
other essential security tools what you may not have heard of however is their conference hardly
strictly security conference this conference is happening april 25th from 8 a.m onward
virtually and it's featuring the topic of everything open source security tooling they'll
have speakers from top companies like versell datadog hashcorp and fastly and it's oriented
towards anybody who cares about open source security tooling whether you're a bug hunter
a red teamer security leader whoever there should be great content for you at this conference so if
you're interested head over to nux.gg slash hss24 slash hss24 right uh hardly strictly security and then
2024 uh to sign up and register and get in on that conference goodness all right with that back to
the show now let's just go ahead and start it and okay you were saying you said when you're using kaido
we're just going to get this on air when you're using kaido what's going on yeah so i still i'm still
going back and forth between kaido and burp um i've gotten into some like more complex workflows recently
like more technical type of um like binary content and like weird protocols and stuff and i found that
it's just these things don't work as well in kaido like kaido works really well for just sort of like
standard type of http work right like plain text or plain text requests plain text responses um and when
you start to dive into more of the binary aspects of for example there's no hex editor right like that's a
that's that's that's a great example right so like i was working with i want to say like protobuf or
something selecting bytes in protobuf and like relying on like the system clipboards to be copying
those like bytes correctly and all it's just like i don't trust it and i don't know how to verify it
and all that kind of stuff so i just end up going to burp for those types of things yeah um yeah and
there are certain things i had the same thing the other day with that like like i was and that's one of
the topics for today was i was taking a look at some of the code behind air chat and they use
grpc on the back end for their api and it's binary based so i was like uh and like there's so many
characters that i couldn't even see and i was like i don't even know how this is working this is kind
of magic and then i put it into burp and saw like turn on hex mode and i saw a bunch of bytes that i
was kind of messing up which is why i was getting bad responses so um yeah the hex editor it's a big
thing for those those you know protobuf for grpc based targets yeah for sure and like it's not i i'm
sure you can make kaido do it with workflows and commit custom commands and all that kind of stuff
but that when i'm using a proxy that's not the type of stuff i want to be fighting with at this time
it needs to be seamless right it needs to like work with well with my flow because if i'm spending a
lot of time trying to make kaido work like burp then that's taking away from the time that i can
spend hacking and it's just like not an efficient use of my time and i will rabbit hole into that it's
been like four hours making kaido do this one thing the same as burp and then i'll be like wait
what was i doing again and it's you know i just find that i have to kind of um you know if i get
into those situations just you know call call and say okay kaido's not there yet switch to burp and then
maybe i'll switch back or you know kind of depends on the workflow or the target yeah i think it's a
maturity thing too you know burp has been around for so long there and they have a really developed
plugin system where you can in you know import like black box um protobuf and all sorts of plugins for
these various systems that people have rabbit hold on and built just like you were talking about for burp
um so i i think as kaido continues to mature um you know we'll we'll see that stuff as well and and
we are seeing it already you know there's new plugins getting released for kaido all the time
um shout out to monke for uh was it kaido pets and kaido nerds did you see kaido
nerds type i didn't see kind of nerds type but i or actually yes i did yes i did okay yeah yeah
so essentially he this is based off of the conversations we've had in uh in you know the
on the pod but essentially you know it adds a right click send to joel you know right click send to
justin interface on kaido which i think is like super clutch and um that's something that i've kind
of been lobbying for as well for for those of you listening i'm um i'm an advisor on kaido's board um
and one of the things i've been kind of lobbying for uh within the kaido ecosystem are sort of
collaboration based features i think that would be really huge um so i'm glad to see some pseudo
collaboration features there coming in from the plugin context and uh yeah let us know if you
for those of you listening let us know if uh if you'd be interested in something like that because uh
might be able to push that along through the system if we have any um you know big promoters of that so
yeah absolutely yeah uh should we talk about this this nagli thread by the way while we're
this is gonna open up a can of worms yeah let's do it okay okay so um i don't even remember if i saw
this like on my feed or somebody sent it to me or whatever but um nagli posted this big long thread
this morning right right at 6 a.m uh totally not scheduled um but it was basically just a rundown of you
know sort of a brain dump from his thoughts and opinions about bdps um vulnerability disclosure
programs right not bug bounty programs but the the non-paying programs um and sort of you know why
he feels like you know they're they're really negative for the platforms whether negative for
hunters uh you know what sort of load they create and whether or not it's even worth having these sort of
things so real quick let's just sort of go over the general claims right um so first of all vdps are
worse for bug bounty hunters worse for paid bug bounty programs they're free labor um you can't you know
you can only find bugs on vdps but you can't pivot that into bug bounty programs um the leaderboard stats
get skewed from vdps and um there are these same scope programs where somebody has a vdp that's like
fully non-paying and then they have a private bug bounty program with the same scope or a limited
subset of that scope that pays um but they don't pay for everything so i'm not a big fan of that last
one man that that last one kind of gets my goat a little bit not gonna lie yeah so i like personally i
rarely ever interact with vdps but i will say my general stance of vdps is fairly similar to nagli's
i don't think that vdps are really a good use of resources for a lot of companies especially the
ones that are primarily using them um and generally speaking i don't know about so much about like you
know the effects on other programs and on hackers and all that kind of stuff we can we'll we can dive
into that for sure um but i definitely think that a lot of the companies that are using vdps
shouldn't be using vdps and what i mean by that is i mean let's call it spade a spade i think the
greatest example of this in history is the red bull program okay or maybe okay or or maybe the the
department of defense i don't know like there's a lot of good good examples defense great example
ford you know another one you know i mean there's too many good examples yeah there's so many big
companies like that yeah almost too many good examples to even be like here's the best example
right which is kind of goes and talks about the problem doesn't it you have these huge huge huge
huge multi-billion dollar companies okay real quick we didn't plan this um ford market cap
ford's market cap is 49.15 billion dollars red bull market cap
red bull's market cap is unknown because i think they're private but somewhere around like
10 billion dollars at least am i reading that right and look at this dude ford's annual gross profit for
2023 was 25 billion so they're operating at like 50 profit margins so there's plenty of space there
for paying researchers 10 grand to find a crit yeah and i i will say right it's not always about
the money like i think anybody who has worked at a company has dealt with finance and has seen sort of
the reality of you know just because the company makes revenue doesn't mean that that revenue is
accessible or usable by by whatever that shouldn't stop you from like emphasizing your security program
right like if you are a 50 billion dollar company you should have at least a little bit of money where
your mouth is on your security team it's an investment too like i feel like most of these
these companies as well you know it's nice to be able to say if you do get popped for example right
it's nice to be able to say well we've been running this bug bounty program and we've been doing you
know this and that and the other thing and you know to at least show like that you're working hard
you know to to take your security seriously and i just feel like vdp doesn't do that yeah now that
being said i think there are there are certainly companies and candidates that fit into a category
where vdps make sense right you've got smaller companies companies that don't have this kind of
funding maybe open source projects um like the internet bug bounty stuff like and even them they
offer bounties right like you know i i think that um there are certainly cases that can be made for
you know non-profits or whatever that who can fit into this category of we want to be receiving
vulnerabilities we don't have the kind of budget and money to pay huge amounts but we want to
recognize in another way are vdp is the solution for that i don't know like again i i think vdps are
like a really crude way of like solving this problem where you want to recognize hackers for their work but
you don't want to do it with money directly and or necessarily incentivize hacking on your program
right or incentivize it at all right because it's like points it's magic internet points that are up
to the platform not even up to like you as the company like there's no skin in the game whatsoever
for ford to give out 50 reputation points right it's literally a click of a button no money no nothing
no anything um and that's not a huge incentive for the program to do things right that's not a huge
incentive for the researchers to even submit stuff right if you find a vulnerability a really critical
vulnerability on a program that has a a vdp where's your incentive to report it directly to that company
so that you can get a pat on the back and maybe a t-shirt or something right like i i think that it's a
really um again it's a crude way of sort of solving this problem and if we're going to allow it to
exist within the space of bug bounty we should probably be limiting limiting it to certain
factors right like what's your total revenue uh are you a non-profit like do you have um any sort of
like extra cash flow like how many employees do you have like i don't know i'm sure the platforms would
probably be better at creating those sort of parameters but i think that vdps are really starting
to take up a space where they shouldn't be and every single hacker i talk to who has interacted with
the vdp that should be paying has the same exact reaction it's like why isn't this company paying
they have the money to pay it right red bull i think for the dod i mean the dod is a little bit of an
edge case i think but um you know i hate to pick on these two companies because i know that there are
other ones that i'm just like not thinking of at the moment but i will say ibm sure right like there
are so many large companies that make a ton of money and could afford to pay and choose not to yeah
right yeah i think i think one of the top points that he made in this this um tweet that he did was
the fact that bug crowd has dropped incentivization for vdps and hacker one i remember them sort of
speaking out like yeah yeah that makes sense you know we'll move in that direction but they haven't
and um and and i i think that's one of the things we're seeing with hacker one a little bit too is this
sort of like companyization of hacker one where it's like okay how is this you know and not to say
that bug crowd and integrity and all the other ones aren't thinking about their like margins or whatever
but like i imagine vdps and having active vdps is a really good onboarding place for hacker one right
like yeah hey you know uh we've already got a vdp set up like we get to talk to you every you know
a couple months or whatever to check in on the vdp or like give you new findings and stuff
it's enough touch points where it's like okay sales becomes much easier when you've got a vdp i guarantee
you there's some dashboard some metric inside of uh you know hacker one sales presentations or it's like
you know 28 of vdps convert to actual bug bounty you know customers or something like that um after
a certain period of time so um i i don't necessarily blame them for for i do i do blame them i i really
think it should not be incentivized and i also hate the fact that there are private vdps
um that's something that for those of you that that that don't know you can turn that off in your
settings um on hacker one and your invite preferences pretty much all the top hackers and all of the
mentees of the top hackers have this turned off like it's one of the first things you do when you
set up your hacker one account um so i would definitely recommend turning those off and i don't
yeah hacker one needs to get rid of those because it's just bad for the ecosystem yeah and somebody
actually mentioned in a reply here apparently and i i i haven't verified this but
yes we hack has no vps at all right so um you know some of the platforms have taken a really really
hard line approach with this where they're not having any vdps whatsoever i think the bottom line
is that not only from a program perspective but or sorry not only from a platform perspective but from a
program perspective you should be paying for security vulnerabilities even if it's a little bit of money
right that's almost a separate discussion of if your bounty table is too low and if you should be
raising it but the fact that there are these companies that are not paying at all really says
a lot about sort of how they view external security research and how they handle that internally right
like if you had a really serious vulnerability the the there's no proper formal route to get a hold of
their security team maybe you could email them or you know you could i guess you could submit it
through their vdp but you know it really just says a lot about sort of where the priorities are for
these for these companies especially the really really big ones that aren't paying um so i would
love to see a more hardline stance on this from the from the platforms what what is your thought on his
like metric of like okay there should be roughly in these are rough calculations and i i tagged yobert to
see if we get actual numbers on this but if there's a similar number of submissions to vdps as there are
bug bounty programs you you're spending you know your triage is spending half of your time triaging vdp bugs
um and that is a lot that is a lot of overhead so i mean what do you think about that yeah so i will say
um i don't know how that works i assume that hacker one has separate triage teams for paying customers
that they do than they do for vdp customers um so i it's hard for me to make a claim about whether or
not that extra you know triage load and the triage burnout and the excess report load and all that kind
of stuff it's really hard to say whether or not that's valid that being said if tomorrow there was a
switch that was flipped and these vdp programs were now private programs not only would they pay the
same amount for triage services but well actually i don't know i mean they must pay for triage services
yeah right so they're probably going to say to pay the same amount for triage services maybe a little
bit more because it's dedicated question mark i'm not sure um but really it's the same triage load right
like you still have the same number of triage people who are going to be dealing with the same
number of reports and all that kind of stuff it's really just maybe more reports and you know more
money overall so it's a private program though now so the volume isn't going to be quite as much though
well they could be a public paying program right they could be yeah they could but going from a vdp
to a public paying program is a pretty ballsy move i think that the best practice is like
like go you know from vdp to buck bounty and private bug bounty you know run that for a year to clean up
your attack surface and then jump right into a public program so this gets to one of the other problem
points doesn't it because the cat is now out of the bag and so you've created an issue where you have
a public vdp but you want to start paying for things but you don't want to go zero to 100 so what do
you do you create a private paying bug bounty program with the same scope and you start to pay
researchers for those vulnerabilities who are invited and you run that for a couple years and
eventually you either phase it over to public or what they probably do is they see oh wow we're still
getting a lot of reports on this public vdp and we're getting a lot of reports on this private vd
private bug bounty program why would we ever merge the two because now we're going to pay a lot more money
right right and they just never do well yeah and and here's here's the thing i i spoke with somebody
who runs a public vdp and a private program bug bounty program i said why are you doing that
and and they said something that was kind of interesting um they said that they actually pay
the vdp submissions um if they meet a certain threshold of reporting so the lows and the lower
mediums they will let sit in the vdp and just accept the report through the vdp the mediums and above
um the it's the mediums the upper mediums are sort of a judgment call do we bring them into the private
program pay them for it or do we just accept it and invite them to the to the private program and
then highs and crits all get moved to the bug bounty program and paid and so i was like okay you know
that's kind of interesting so it's sort of like an onboarding mechanism for the people that are using
your app notice a bug and and submit it and then you're not robbing them okay so let me pick your
brain about that a little bit so first of all is do all the submissions go through the vdp or are some
people on both and they just everybody everybody who's in the private program just submits to the
private program okay and so anything that's you know medium high end of medium or above and should be in
the main program gets moved from it came in through vdp gets moved to the main program and then exactly
and then they they pay it off they pay it you know they pay the researcher for that submission even
though they submitted to a vdp okay so how do you feel about that kind of a good idea right like like
to be honest i'd be pretty happy if for some reason you know i submitted a bug to a vdp in some
world justin submitted a bug to a vdp um then and i got it got moved into the bug bounty program and i
got paid for it i would have a ton of you know sort of brand affinity for that for that target right
okay so so how as a hacker how do you feel about that process of not only having sort of two places
to report um but getting paid like regardless of the vdp existence like if you submit a good bug you're
still gonna get paid like this does that still annoy you in the same way that they have a vdp you know
so i said in the beginning i really don't like that structure and i think what i don't like about
it is the fact that if you had known somebody who's in the public program or the private program
then and you sent them a dm saying hey i got a bug can you submit it you know and they submit it to the
program then it's like okay so why can't i just submit it to the program or like you know you dm someone
and say hey you know i know this this program's got like a private program can can i get added to it or
whatever i found a bug there um and you can't really submit a bug to the vdp and be like hey
i've got a bug but i know you've got a bug bounty program so give me access to that because that just
feels extortiony right so it's like i don't know it the the times when they don't pay the researcher is
not great but the times when they do pay the researcher anyway i'm actually not super opposed
to that structure i don't know okay maybe that's awesome so here's a follow-up let's say they had a
public paying bug bounty program they merged the two but they had the same policy lows and lows and
anything under 5.5 or whatever cbss zero bounty they only pay they'll accept everything but they'll
only give bounties for things that are medium and above yeah i mean i don't love it to be honest with
you okay you know it's the same thing but i don't love it you know okay feels bad because they might
as well just pay for it all if they're gonna pay for some of it or it's just not competitive at that
point like it's like why would i spend time on this right because there's there's plenty of programs
that pay for lows and mediums and you know you know i'm a big medium advocate i love a good medium man
i love a good medium okay what if the incentive is like high enough like let's say like you know
lows and mediums hypothetically flat payout for loads of mediums let's say it's like 500 bucks and then
like high ends of mediums and high started like 5k you know if they're paying 500 for medium and this
is a newer program you know you know it's not it's not the worst my standard is 750 for a medium uh it's
moving towards 1k for a medium actually um but yeah i don't know man i feel like i feel like when you
when you pulled that you know hit me with that uno reverse uno card there and i was like oh wait a
second i would hate that if it was if it was a public bounty program with no lows and medium bounties it
kind of opens the eyes i just think the vdp is like i think it makes sense that structure makes
sense for people that don't want to get overwhelmed but also want to pay researchers what they're due
and so that's kind of why i like like that approach um does that make sense yeah oh yeah i think it's
fair enough i was just kind of curious from like you know the full-time hackers perspective of like what
you know because it's basically the same thing right it's basically the same thing because you know
basically they're still not paying for loads and whatever's but they're just being transparent that
if something higher comes in they're going to pay for it but um but i don't know man there's there's
a different thing because you know the full-time bug bounty hunter this is a different this is a
different conversation because most most companies don't want or aren't going to be on our radar right
the the only people that are going to be on our radar are people that are really top level programs
right because we're going to be working with them long term we're going to have a committed
relationship with that program um and if you're not ready to pay up for that like i've been talking
to some programs recently i've said hey look i love your program i use your product all the time
you know normally just as a part of my life i would love to hack you because i know this product inside
outside upside down and i've got all my data in it and i've got everything configured right be awesome
your boundaries aren't there you know i can't do it because of this this this you know and and it's just
it's a shame but it's also where some programs are at maturity wise is they they can only pay to
incentivize mid-grade hackers and that's fine okay now here's this is gonna get a little deep
there is a longer than i anticipated on this yeah sorry i'm gonna let you cook because this you're a
program manager so this is like yeah no i think this is a good conversation so so i will say like there's
definitely a weird balance coming i've noticed and i don't think many people have noticed it but i
certainly have noticed it between like revenue budgets inflation and bounty tables okay and you
could probably already sort of piece those things together but for one the economy is like doing all
sorts of weird weird things right weird weird things right now inflation is still through the
roof and continuing to go up at like a really crazy rate i haven't checked that recently that's interesting
bounty tables are also inflating in my opinion quite significantly not fast enough from the hacker's
perspective but way too fast from a program perspective what and don't open up this can of worms right
now are you kidding me i mean just think about this okay think about this criticals a good critical on
on a bug bounty program in 2019 would be 10k like that's like the high end of of crates like at most
the program's paying 20k crates okay like top top programs 2019. 2024 there are plenty of companies
who offer at least 50k crates 100k crates even higher especially for the crypto programs yeah that's
okay a solid crit payment right now is 20k like i will look at a program that has a 20k crit if you
want to get above a 20k crit that's when you you get really into the like okay this is on the hit list
like i will hack this program at some point you know true but the 50k ones i almost and and i've
gotten a couple 50k bounties and it's great and it feels awesome but they are hard to get the
companies to pay and they are oftentimes on very specialized scope yeah right so i will say like i
i think the hard part is not so much that like most people are ending up paying those critical bounties
i think it's more that because the table ends up there the next levels have to be significantly higher
right so high vulnerabilities starting at like 10 or 15k and medium starting at like five or two and a
half right those are yeah you love to see it but then from like a program perspective you make one
little slip up there's one like medium severity vulnerability and it's like thousands of dollars
out of the budget right and so um in order to be competitive like you said like as a top level hacker
you see a program that's paying like 3k 5k i don't know is 5k crits enough for you to hack or not anymore
so 5k 5k crits i will not i will not normally hack on um unless i have some other instant incentivization
right so that's like still pretty good like that's probably the average crit payout for most programs that
don't have a ton of budget and you know they are basically off the radar for a lot of the top
hackers because they can't compete financially with the bounty tables that the really big programs have
and so they just can't attract that attention and so it's just a very very difficult situation i think
like i'd love to see bounty tables continuing to grow and and companies to continue to put more and more
money behind you know their their security teams and all that kind of stuff but then either those
single slip ups or in order to stay competitive and have an edge against other programs it's like
there's always that like classic joke right of like the lemonade stand right where you're like
there's two guys selling lemonade and one guy's at like 40 cents and the other guy's at 50 cents
and so then the guy next to him drops his down to 40 cents and then the guy next to him drops
just the 30 cents and then 20 cents 10 cents and then the guy next to it buys all of his product
puts about a business and raises it back to 40 cents right and so it's just like the kind of the
same thing but without like the acquisition cost so much where basically there's a race to the top
for bounty tables where the programs who have highest bounties and the least vulnerabilities
get the most attention or like close to the top and a lot of scope you know what i mean like
there's a balance between scope and bounties where you're on the like yeah epic games uh
let's let's we gotta be careful you know what i'm saying i know what you're saying yeah yeah um
yeah other examples shopify um you know but yeah they're definitely it's it's kind of like a race to
the top with the bounty tables where the higher the bounty table the more attention and sort of stuff you
get um but then it becomes even harder for smaller programs to compete with that at all because there's
so much attention being garnered from these 15k highs 5k medium right and so it's like that's a
part of the game like like it is part of the game but you know we're also simultaneously saying oh you
know like vdps like you should be a paying program and then they become a paying program and they're like
screw you we don't it doesn't even matter because they can't even compete right like they can't even
like they can't put 20k crits down so like yeah it's it's definitely challenging at least you're
gonna get at least you're gonna get the the the mid-tier hackers though and and there are some very
very very talented mid-tier hackers you know yeah and and you know this whole hacker tier system that
i'm talking about is like totally arbitrary and like yeah essentially a figment of our imagination you
know there are some every every hacker has their unique eyes and are going to be able to find
something that other hackers can't find we see that every single live hacking event um but yeah i
mean you're still going to attract some hackers that have lower standards dude if you live if i lived in
argentina you know if i lived in in india yeah if i lived in some of these places where like the amount
of money you need to spend to have an awesome life is so much less then i would absolutely hack on a 5k
crit program because it's like okay that 5k crit uh results in you know this much spend for me which
is the lifestyle that i want to live and there are tons i know many many many hackers that are very
skilled doing the digital nomad thing where if they get 5k they're set for you know two months and it's
like i will say i think like that's probably one of the like hugest like life-changing aspects of bug
bounty like it's always been like you know life-changing amounts of money to some extent
depending on where you are but i think especially in countries that are a lot more like their economies
are struggling a lot more they're um a lot less developed and stuff like what we would call a
small bounty right like 500 or something i mean walk up to anybody and give them 500 outside the us and
even in the us right it's like it's a it's a huge amount of money right and so i think um bug bounty
is like doing a ton in that area but there's still too many bdps right like you don't want to be taking
somebody who has that kind of talent and is struggling and then abusing that like their time
and their energy and stuff and not giving them money even if it's a small amount of money that's going
to change their life right like give them 150 or whatever that that you were gonna spend on team
lunch or whatever the and like you know like change somebody's life instead of having a vdp
yeah that's my call to action yeah i agree man no it's good it's and it's it's funny you know i i
talked to somebody that got actually a massive bounty and lives in one of these countries that it's like
this is literally like hitting the lottery you know it's like yeah you know your life has changed
forever your family's life has changed forever it's like it's it's crazy so um really exciting for
people living in those in those regions of the world and uh yeah for anybody who's willing to
make that lifestyle switch to go and live in those countries because um you know lots of lots of
awesome opportunities there um sorry i didn't i didn't mean to derail that too much uh i'm looking
at your program here man you got you got uh the tinder program 10 10k highs you know uh 2k mediums at
minimum i'm just saying um all right all right i'll just say what do i need to do to compete i'm
sorry man i'd see the thing is i don't use tinder like if i was a single dude if i was a single dude
that uses tinder yeah there's two two big two big conditions that are not fulfilled here um then i
would i would absolutely hack on it um but uh you know i don't so that that's yeah well all i'm saying
is i think we both known that um sometimes those barriers make for great programs to hack on because
it it deters a lot of people so even if you are a non-single person who doesn't use tinder if you're
willing to get on tinder and use tinder and try and hack it um you know you'll have an edge on other
people make sure you tell your wife in advance yeah honey i yeah you're gonna get some weird dms from
your single friends like um justin's yeah oh that's great okay so i we actually have another kind of
like a program hacker debate uh okay hold up hold up hold up i actually i'm sorry i'm not done with
this noggly tweet noggly oh okay you screwed us here man because now we're talking 30 minutes into
this podcast still on the same thing um what do you think about the leaderboard thing like i i thought
that was i think that is one of the things that needs to change absolutely it's like you know this
whole gamification piece of bug bounty is awesome and is a major major major motivator for a lot of the
hackers um and hackers that spend times on hard like the hackers like myself and others that spend
time specifically looking for the hardened the most hardened programs they can find you know um
and and try to try to hack on these programs are not seeing as good of a return or as good a placement
on these leaderboards or even people that just hack bug bounty programs in general uh because of the
presence of vdps and somebody commented i i want to say it was let me look down here i want to say it
was uh piku haku um from the discord yeah um and said that essentially uh the number one hacker on
integrity right now too is a vdp only program and i saw them kind of get into it on twitter the other day
there's like a twitter argument about like you know you found 28 bugs or whatever and i found 28 bugs this
morning you know and it's like who's the better hacker and i'm like uh the guy that's hacking the
paid program for sure um so i don't know what are your thoughts on that yeah so i i also like
gamification is fine right i i i think everything's gonna get gamified if they don't do it some other
hacker is gonna do it right nagly's intelligence network or whatever yeah he's gonna build his own
leaderboard and whatever but that being said these are not the same thing right vdps and bug bounty
programs i don't think are the same thing and the fact that there is um this alternative method of
earning the same points like it doesn't feel right to me if we're gonna have points let's keep it what it
is right and let's either delineate it separately bug bounty reputation vdp reputation vdp signal vdp
you know whatever or don't even include it entirely do what bug bug crowd did remove the points aspect
from it you don't get any points for any of that stuff it doesn't affect your stats at all if you
want to be a good guy hacker and you want to submit stuff to vdps and you want to get your practice on
there that's great but you're not going to get any stats for that because yeah that's not bug bounty
program reflective stats that's bdp reflective stats yeah and you know i'm not i think it should be a
separate leaderboard i think you know i think you should get bug bounty rep and you should get other
rep because it is a good like why hide it right like yeah if you want if you spend a bunch of time
doing that that's fine but i think to make to combine them is a little bit misleading both to
people who look at the leaderboards but also to the people who are like trying to get up on the
leaderboard right you could go hack on a bunch of vdp programs that are have much more scope lower
barrier for entry like easier to farm points all that kind of stuff and you'll see exactly what's
happening the people on the top of the leaderboards um or a lot of the people who are in the top of of
the leaderboards are vdp hackers right they're people who are hacking on vdps they're earning a ton of
points from from vdps and to try and compete from a purely bug bounty program perspective extremely
extremely difficult like you would have to go out of your way to probably hack on vdps just to get
points so that you can compete on the same number of reports and all that kind of stuff if you're just
a bug bounty program hacker and again it's fine like to hack on vdps get the points for it that's
great but from the programs or sorry for like i keep missing mixing but the platforms hacker one bug
crowd right they should be listing these things separately don't put somebody's you know 10 000 rep
when 8 000 of that is from the dod program and 2 000 of it is from pay programs right like put that
separate so that people can see oh they've got a ton of rep from this i i think this actually extends
um even further uh if we're if we're going to talk about leaderboards this is a complaint i've had
about this as well is like the program leaderboards do the same exact problem right you go to any
program you look at their leaderboard you see who's on the top of the leaderboard right top five top 10
you're gonna have thousands and thousands of rep but you go and look at uh the thanked hackers and
you look at this year you could go back i i've done this like five years back six years back until i
actually hit when they got 2 000 rep on that program when the top hacker and the hacker hasn't hacked on
this program since before covid and they're still at the top of the leaderboard because they farmed the
hell out of the program when it first launched they got a ton of rep and they haven't touched
it since and you're looking at this and you're like wow how am i ever going to get 4 000 rep on
this program and it's it's just very hard to get like accurate right it's a different game it's a
different perspective and like yeah all time stats that person really crushed the program but so much
has changed since then they might have a different scope they might have a different bounties they might
have a different everything and you're still seeing this person as the number one hacker on this program
um and i and i think like it's it's a similar aspect where it's really hard like you can infer
a lot of things and i think a lot of people are inferring the wrong things when they see these right
you look at the top leaderboard you see somebody with 10 000 rep you're thinking this person hacks
a lot they make a lot of bounties they're getting a lot of really valid reports if you were to see the
breakdown of bbp versus vdp rep it's probably going to tell a very different picture and the same thing
goes for you know like the the rep on the top hackers on a program let's look at how much rep they've
gotten in the last 90 days or the last three or the last 360 days the 365 days instead of all time
and it's going to tell a very different picture yeah i think this is a great point for hacker one
too is like that top hacker they moved that to the bottom by the way i don't know if you noticed that
yeah i don't i don't love that uh but they they moved it to the bottom and it defaults to top hackers
of all time i think it should default to the last 365 days because and i think hack one would really
benefit from that too because common mistake in the beginning everyone made it like you mentioned
was going there and being like oh you know freaking today's new has like you know a thousand rep on
this program i'm never going to find anything yeah you know one flood mentality we've talked about this
many times we're not going to repeat it again but two he hasn't touched the program in you know a year
or two years and so if you do that running leaderboard one that's incentivizes you to continue to hack on
a program if you want to maintain your leaderboard status but also it doesn't scare away those people
that are um just not gonna look at the program if some top hacker has been looking at it in in the past
you know year or whatever so i think it could be a really good move for hacker one and i think it would
help um sort of solidify some of that uh that yeah yeah and what i'll say is just as a recent example
of this with the public program shopify okay you go to shopify's all-time leaderboard their top hackers h13
dash he's got 3900 rep all time you set that to 2024 he's not even on he's not even listed you set
that to 2023 not even listed you set that to 2022 now he's listed he's got 680 rep right so we're two
years out and overall a year and a half whatever and that this hacker hasn't even they're still at the
top of the leaderboards right so this it's just not a very accurate way of sort of looking at things and
i think it's a little too broad and and generalized in terms of like how a lot of stats are being shown
and how the leaderboards and stuff work um and yeah i think it would be good to see a little bit more
separation and granularity on that data from just like a user's perspective of if i just visit someone's
program or someone's profile maybe only show the bug bounty program rep and stats by default and if
i want to see their bdp rep and stats there's a drop down or or something like that you know like right
right show both at the same time or yeah whatever right like there's got to be a better way to show
this that's not as confusing um and not as easy to sort of game right because i i think a lot of this
boils down to people are gaming this in a negative way that's not fair to the people who aren't gaming
it yeah yeah i agree and and so yeah i think that leaderboard piece could be really cool i i got a
little nerd sniped for a second um you know because i looked at the activity on shopify and i see our
boy my mom bear is just crushing it out here this man is getting bounty over bounty over bounty so nice
job dude rocking it hey guys real quick i just wanted to give a shout to the hacker content team they
have been absolutely killing it the past couple months taking the content from the podcast and
condensing it down into consumable social media posts whether it be shorts or text posts or whatever
they've been rocking it so i just wanted to give them a shout out and let you know that they do all
sorts of cyber security content as well as social media management they do technical blogs they do
comprehensive social media management so if your organization could benefit from any of those types of
services make sure you head over to hackercontent.com drop them a line and mention the podcast when you do to get
your first month of cyber security content marketing services for free all right that's it let's get
back to the pot you know what i think we're gonna cut noggly's tweet off there noggly thanks for 40
minutes of content this uh this this week geez dude um okay so yeah let's continue the whole uh program uh
versus hacker debate you know version two somebody was asking about this in the discord too so um it's good
we we fell into that um let me ask you about this so um i've run into this situation a couple times in
the past where there is a very common issue that happens across many many endpoints on a target okay
and this this issue is um let's say it's there's an issue more often than there's not an issue with
this target with these specific set of endpoints with this specific vulnerability okay okay but there
are endpoints that have the correct access controls in place okay so clearly there's some access control
system in place what do you think about making it like up seeing you know 20 reports come in for this
specific um thing and realizing hey our current implementation is flawed and really we should
just shove this off in middleware or something like that um but then you've got to undo all of the code
in those other functions and then put the middleware in and then you know so it's not it's it's sort of a
global fix but also you're undoing code in functions that were not vulnerable whereas the normal standard
would be like okay if i changed uh you know some code in this specific function for this specific endpoint
then it's a fix for that endpoint and that gets a unique bounty that's a normal standard um but so rather
than that you fix at the middleware level and then you remove the previous you know flawed checks from
the endpoints that were not vulnerable um i feel like that's sort of a sneaky way to get around it
and i feel like what would happen is if you sent in one report at a time then they'd be like oh i just
need to copy and paste this you know access control check from this function into that function then they
fix it in that individual visual function then you send the next one then you send the next one
you know and so do you continue with this sort of incomplete or sort of flawed model um or do you
you know try to take a different approach and if you learned from the the hackers submitting 20 reports
that this is a you know massive problem do you pay them for all 20 reports uh and then you know i don't
know what what are your thoughts on that you see what i'm saying i don't know if that was yeah yeah
yeah so i'll talk generically about this um so my stance is that generally these things kind of end
up working themselves out almost the same way um and so typically what happened let's let's run through
both scenarios the first scenario is that um you have this semi-systemic issue you find in a lot of
different endpoints you're submitting them one at a time as the program gets them they pay them
basically let's say the same bounty for every single one um and that's sort of how it goes the other
way is that you submit uh or maybe there's three options the the second option is that you submit
uh all 20 at the same time and they or is that are those just the two options for submissions either
you slow roll them or or you do them all at once so you know the slow roll i think it's pretty clear
that if they fix it globally from the slow roll then then it's not a global issue you know it's not an
issue that you should get paid for each one of them um so on the other hand yeah there is that aspect
of like okay well we looked at the code and we found 20 other functions that you couldn't see because
they're not in the js files and we don't have any api docs leaking you know that was vulnerable and this
is actually a massive issue um so so that second yeah that second scenario like if if the program
discovers significantly more impact that it was a systemic issue they didn't know about i would say
nine times out of ten nine and a half times out of ten nine point nine times out of ten
program is never gonna even let you know that that was a thing yeah um and they're gonna fix it
i thought you were gonna say the office i was like do you do not say that like no no no no no i mean
obviously it's in the programs it's like best interest to pay as little money as possible right like
that's that's where the incentive lies um uh that's just you know economics right what's wrong with you
man it's the hackers uh goal to earn as much money as possible it's the program's job to pay as little
money as possible right that's just how the economics uh work um that being said there is like ethics
an ethics side here right so i think like a really highly ethical and transparent program which are very
few of who go to this length would be like hey as we were just looking into this we found that this
is actually a really huge problem so we're gonna pay it out that is rare for a lot of reasons mainly like
money because it's literally just like lighting extra money on fire and like going to find an impact
where you're gonna pay more money um you know it's it's rarely a good justification when you're like
trying to explain why you paid 50 instead of paying like 20. you know what i mean um yeah so so
there's there's that aspect to it um like that scenario however i think as i was saying most of
the time these sort of merge into the same sort of resolution because if you submit 20 of the same
vulnerability then they for sure know okay like there's some sort of weird systemic thing here we
need to look into this and figure out what's going on and they're gonna fix it systemically and most
likely i would say the program's gonna pay a higher bounty but close those all as one issue
because it's going to get fixed in one place um if you were to slow roll them initially they're gonna
fix them one at a time and then after like four they're gonna be like this is probably systemic and
they're gonna look into it well they should they should look into it find that's just that it's systemic
and then every single report after that they're gonna say okay this is a known issue we're working on
fixing this we're not going to pay them out as as additional bounties um and then it's probably
close to the same bounty uh depending on how many reports you you managed to sneak through or what
they paid for it yeah right um and maybe you as a researcher you could make that case and be like hey
you know i actually had a bunch more of these like can we agree on you know paying like a portion
of you know like the total that i had found or you know i don't know that that's a little more
complicated but i think generally the program if they're doing their job well like after four or
five of the same type of report on like you know systemic thing they should be seeing okay this is
weird this looks like it's a systemic let's figure out what's going on here and again we're back into
the incentive model here where like the program is going to try and want to try and get on top of it
they're going to try and figure out what's going on in the back end they want to create tickets to make
sure that they're getting ahead of this so that when more reports come in for that same issue
they can say oh we're actually already working on a fix here dude can i just go back to your whole
like the program is incentivized to not pay just like dude okay so here's what i don't get i understand
the whole ethical conundrum of like okay i have been entrusted with this responsibility um by my
employer and i should be giving my employer you know my best effort and that sort of thing um but also
these are massive massive companies that have you know massive massive revenue and and stuff and these
researchers are doing quality research that that are fixing vulnerabilities this is not like we paid
500 grand for nessus you know it's like it it this is this is actual here's a volum a valid one you fix
here's the money you know it's a pretty clear exchange and it's high value as in you're getting
something worth money for what you're paying um so i don't understand people's hesitancy to push around
and and maybe this this comes from my my experience you know not having to deal with finance but you
know pushing around and saying like hey listen we have technical you know debt we have problems that
we need to fix that were taken from improper architecting and cutting edges you know sometimes whatever
it is in in code development and and that's a price we need to pay and it's not something that you can
really say no to because it's putting users at risk and that risk is much greater than the you know 2k
we're gonna so i i just like if i were on your side i feel like i would say i i am fighting for the
researcher as much as to pay them as much as i can because they're they're they're producing value and i can
and i can see that and i can validate that and i don't have as much high hopes for other money that's
being spent in the organization about whether you know jim is spending you know two hours a week at
the freaking watering you know talking to people and shooting the and then going to his company paid
lunch for you know two hours it's like like maybe i'm being too too pessimistic on that but it just i feel
like there's so much bs in so many companies especially when you get above a certain size
where people are not actually doing anything for the money they're they're they're getting and bug
bounty is always going to be a here's something worth value yeah so bug bounty is like a weird it's
like if it falls into a weird spot right because it's both it assigns a financial value to like
security problems and it it puts like a really hard dollar value on like it mistakes um and we try not
to like assign blame on things but it makes it really difficult not to when you pay a 10 000 bounty
and it's like okay paying that the company's paying that like well okay so so think about how this works
you know where you get it but think about it this way no no no it's not even about the budget side
right think about it this way okay you paid ten thousand dollars because uh security vulnerability
was found who should have found that okay i see where this is going you know maybe the security team
or a code review or something like that or the person that wrote it yeah and when should they have found
it when they were developing it yeah there's actually like multiple places where they probably should
have found it right like during review during like pre-review during pre-release like during post-release
like there's many many different spots where like the security team probably had opportunities to to
identify that vulnerability and didn't and now or you there's is that what you're saying or the the
security team well right like yeah the security team or the mostly like the security team as a whole
we'll just say like somebody somebody somewhere within the security team probably at some point
should have had an opportunity to identify that if they didn't the process is not great um and that
like speaks to other things right but there's like this sense of blame where it now there's like a
monetary value on this vulnerability where somebody missed it and now that cost a lot of money and i think
that makes it a little bit easier to justify to leadership in terms of like hey there's a real cost
of security where if we don't find these vulnerabilities and we don't have the processes in
place to be looking through this stuff properly then it's going to cost us a lot of money and vulnerabilities
but then there's also the side of
i want to pay the researcher at least as what's fair but ideally as much as possible right and so those two
things are are like hard to balance because paying what's fair can be really tricky because maybe
there's like a legacy problem there's a lot of vulnerabilities you didn't know about now you you
have like a budget problem but paying as much as possible is also like a a hard budget problem because
now you're like we want to pay as much money we want to create as much spend on these problems as
possible to try and incentivize them to be fixed but all it really does is make finance really annoyed
that you're spending so much money you know who cares who cares about annoying finance like like
i mean maybe this is my this is very probably i will preface this by saying this is from a very
privileged position of i have not ever had to deal with corporate crap i i did consulting for two years
and i've been self-employed ever since and i never am going back um but also who cares because at the end
of the day it's not like i feel like bug bounty should have that you know that that check of like
listen if you don't pay the money then you're accepting the risk implicitly that your users are
going to get screwed and that is so much more expensive like look at the look at the um look at
the hack right total overall cost for that like 110 million dollars does run you know a bug bounty program
for years and years and years and they've only paid out what like 12 million you know like it's not it's
like it's a drop right so i think cyber like you know cyber security insurance and stuff has also like
all of the ways of putting monetary incentives and values on parts of cyber security and like hacking and
stuff has created direct incentive models where it's easier to justify to the company why this spend needs
to exist and why it is what it is right and i think that's that's very good um but it's still
like a hard like you still have to sell it right because at the end of the day it's always going to
be a financial burn where not only are you like doing your security stuff but then you're spending
extra money to like pay extra researchers and you know you you have to somehow you know justify that
that money like for finance i mean the reality is they'll just give you less money you know what i mean
like it's a very privileged it's a very privileged like yeah sure sure they control the budget right
they say you know we feel like you're spending too much money so you need to spend less money and then
the security team basically has to figure out okay if we're going to spend less money uh if we want to
pay the same amount in bounties then we need to spend less money on other things or we have to figure
out how to pay less bounties who does that go up through because like what what i would how i would
respond to that is that you know finance saying hey we're going to pay you less money and then i would
try to get some statistics that say okay you know this less money is going to result in this amount of
decreased findings or this amount of like oh we don't have enough time to go over x amount of code
you know if you're even talking about normal security stuff like we need one more security engineer
and we're not going to get it so it's going to be you know less amount of time looking at this code
which means x amount of vulnerabilities introduced which means x additional risk and then you just push that up the
line and you say okay listen ceo like would you like to inc you know experience a 12 you know 20
increase in uh cyber security risk or would you like to pay an extra you know 200 grand or whatever
it is a year to get that down to a reasonable level and then also have that in place with you know get get
this is this is like i said could be totally off but like then you then you're putting it up back up to
the finance people it's like okay listen now there's a 20 risk of you know whatever cyber incident at
10 million you you run the math you know like well yeah so so i think you know it's very complicated
and a lot of this is just completely hypothetical like speculation but i think a lot of finance teams
would probably come back and say you know like well why can't you just spend less on bug bounty like
why can't you offer lower bounties like and still we're still incentivizing people to hack but like why
can't you know why can't you pay 5k crits instead of 20k crits right like it's still incentivizing and
putting money where our mouth is but like why do we need to spend you know 20k on a critical when we
could pay 20k for a critical or 5k for critical yeah um and you know that's a that's a difficult
one or like if you go over budget and you need to pull money from other places and it's like okay where
do we pull like where do we decide that we don't need money for so that we can spend it on bug bounty
bounty or you know like so it's a very complicated like why i don't want your job dude all right yeah
i do not want your job because i would get in these meetings i'd be like listen here like
and finance would not like me at all no i don't think so no yeah so i mean like this is like the
the weird like complicated side of like the back-end side where you know when you i think you're getting a
little more respect when you look at programs who have paid so much money or pay like a ton of money all
the time because when you think about it from a cash flow perspective or even just a budgeting
perspective the fact that they're able to continually get that amount of money or get like or have those
types of funds to spend on bug bounty says a lot about where the company's head is at for security
right like i think all of the things that you want are totally reasonable and i would like them too but
it it comes from a very privileged uh point of view from a security perspective where it basically
assumes that like all the upper leadership including the people in finance and accounting
value security to like a high level and think that security is worth like an act like a dollar value
it's a budget item enough to say like okay yeah we're gonna put like a million dollars a year or whatever
towards paying bounties not even like the platform fees or anything else just like bounties right
and that is a line item and so i i think you know it just you have to have that sort of buy-in from upper leadership and all that kind of stuff and having everybody else think that it's as important
and again i think this is why things like cyber insurance for example have started to make a bit of
a change where when a company has a cyber security insurance policy that says that they're gonna you
know if they have a breach they're gonna have to pay pay out like 10 million dollars or whatever well
then depending on how much you're spending on bug bounty that's way worth it because then you don't have to
fall on your cyber security insurance policy and pay out a bunch of money and have all these other problems
there is an actual cost like cost benefit analysis that you can do there but when when you're like
we just want to pay more in bounties like it's very hard to justify like if finance for example like
the situation i said finances oh why can't we just pay 5k crits instead of 20k crits how do you generate
the data that says well by paying 5k we're gonna get less submissions we're gonna like all like
quantitatively we're gonna get this many less submissions and that's gonna account for like
this much less money but this much more risk and that risk equates to this much potential cyber security
risk and like there's so much like matt like you might as well like legit be like an insurance actuator
when you're trying to calculate this kind of stuff and it's just it's so complicated that i think a lot of
programs just take what they can get and they pay what they can and they hold on to the money that
they can and when you have programs that have a ton of budget and a ton of respect for their security
team and their bug bounty programs it shows in how they can spend their bounties but it's usually pretty
obvious i don't know yeah i i hope that answers that that was a hard one to answer it does and and you
need the data you know that's that that is a good a good a good point and that takes a lot of work to
get and it's not super readily available i will say something though when you mentioned uh insurance
the the insurance piece is is really interesting because i bet after a breach your insurance premiums go
up a lot you know what happens when you get in a car accident yeah exactly right so you know i bet that
110 million number that uh you know a lot of people saw that number i think for mgm i think i'm
remembering the number right and we're like whoa that's crazy and then other people are like oh it's
just covered by cyber insurance i'm like mgm has a paying bug bounty program right yeah yeah and and so
um you know cyber cyber insurance that amount is going to go up substantially uh and so i don't know
it's it's crazy i would love to see the calculations that they're doing like i would love to know how
they're waiting because yeah i mean this is what actuaries do right they do like these really
complicated mathematical um like probabilities on all these different things happening i'd love to
know what sort of um factors that they're thinking about when they're calculating that kind of cyber
cyber security insurance stuff because um it would be really interesting to see how they're weighing
like the the risk just like kind of what i talked about right like okay we lower our criticals
so that we can pay more bounties or more individual bounties right in theory but what does that do to
risk does that increase the risk of us getting a worse vulnerability that we didn't know about
not through the bug bounty program or does it increase the number of bugs that we're going to
receive because now we can pay more or like you know i don't know kind of paying the price anyway
yeah yeah yeah right like i don't know it's i see that yeah one more point here before we move
along okay because we're already an hour in and i i can't spend super long today um
this was going to the staffing versus bug bounty money conversation
bug bounty bug bounty doesn't take a break you know bug bounty doesn't spend time on a useless email
you know but bug bounty doesn't do any of that crap you know um and i think that should make it a much
easier conversation with with finance it's like listen when we hire someone we are agreeing to pay
them x amount of money regardless of their performance regardless of their their uh you know
uh whatever right that's inherently risky because you don't know how they're going to perform and you
do your best to to pick somebody who will but it's a risk and you don't have that risk with poke downy
because you're only ever paying for results and i think that should make the sell much easier like
listen listen finance every single time we pay out here it's it's actually fixing something and you're
buying something you know like you're getting some result um so i don't know that that's just yeah
it's just yeah and then we'll move along but it's just crazy complicated calculus right it's like yeah
that that is that is true you know until you pay enough crits and then suddenly the math is all out of
whack so yeah it's it's just one of those weird things that like i think from a bug bounty hunter's
perspective it doesn't matter so much the nitty-gritty but you can you can tell
sort of like how finances when you're dealing with a lot of programs based on like how fast they pay and
how much they pay and how loose they are with bounties and all that kind of stuff yeah all right
dude um we're an hour in i'm looking at the rest of the topics and they are not at all related to
nope okay actually i've got one semi-related one and then we'll cut it and we'll move the content to
next week um okay keep it sort of on topic with this whole um hacker versus program thing let me ask
you this um what is what is your thought on walling off endpoints as a permanent fix and as a band-aid fix
and do does it happen and like like with a waft or like with a with a reverse proxy um yeah what are your thoughts
oh it happens all the time for sure i think the greatest example of this is like you know like a year ago or six months ago
and all those zero days kept popping up and like apache and spring boot and there were all these really core fundamental problems
um the first line of fixes that you would see would be add this to your detection rules add this you know
block these requests that are containing these parameters and stuff right so that for sure happens
and i think it's a great immediate fix because when you have something that affects you number one priority
is making sure that you're not vulnerable and the only way to do that is to either patch the code and deploy it
or to stop requests and then patch the code and deploy it and so i think a lot of companies first
thing they want to do is lock that down make sure that they you know they can't be exploited externally
then they can figure out you know what they need to change what they need to fix whatever as long as
it's not going to impact things and then they can go from there um i don't really see any problems with
it i definitely think from like a security response perspective it's probably like the best and fastest
thing that you can do in the moment oftentimes if it's just a normal bug bounty report depending on
the severity i don't know about if it needs to be handled in that sense um let's see maybe okay yeah
then yeah probably like you i think i would want the program to respond as soon as possible maybe you
can explain a little bit more of the context let me ask this because i think we've had a debate i think
this is actually in the last hacker program debate where we were like okay you know volna in a third
party just whaff it off and you're like just laugh it off like you know what do you mean just laugh
it off like that takes time and effort and i'm like just laugh it off man it's just an nginx config or
like a you know go into cloudflare or whatever but maybe i'm i'm wrong about that you know like and i
don't know if this is actually something that you're doing in your day-to-day or whether you've got like
teams associated for this but let's say you want to laugh off an endpoint where like you know nginx
reverse proxy off an endpoint um like does this go through the the whole this is such a weird
question does this go through the whole dev process are you like just s like this is this is now i feel
embarrassed you know asking it this way like so you just ssh into prod and like modify the nginx config like
i would say at most companies that have at least 50 employees that's never going to happen um smaller
smaller smaller startups like one thing you'll notice startups less employees less process less
procedure everything's a lot more scrappy everything is much more like oh just tell dan the ssh into the
box and like you know whatever like yeah exactly like so it's in prod exactly right like that type of
stuff once you start to grow and there's a lot more procedures and processes in place you have like
you know people in charge and managing and stuff you the those things are harder for a lot of different
reasons at its fundamental level it's a security reason right that people shouldn't just be able to
like ssh into the box and change that kind of stuff right like that's that's risky um so typically
there's what i think is commonly referred to as like a break glass process where essentially in these p0
scenarios there are certain layers of approval whether that's through like it or a director or some
high-level manager who's in charge of this process they might get paged on call or something like that
um you know the people who are basically in in charge of these emergency response processes and
there will be special approvals that can go in place to push a change like that um and usually it's not
just that like one person has the ability to do that it does need to go through some layers but those layers
exist for those for those p0 those super high critical risk cases where something needs to happen at two
o'clock in the morning or whatever wow yeah that's it's it's so much i think that's something that's really
high value to understand too because i think um there are there have been some scenarios in the past
where you i was just reading through some old reports where you can access where you can bypass
those sort of nginx config stuff it was on the on the um you know uh uh 2023 top web hacking techniques
one of the top ones was like here's these characters you stick at the ends of urls or whatever and you can
you know you can get through and i just love that i love the idea of that and um and so i think it
it really makes a lot of sense for researchers to pay attention to security architecture in that way
and if people are laughing off endpoints and and uh you know doing apache blocks or whatever then
knowing what kind of back end stack is in place and how the front end um proxy is dealing with various
routes and and what data will be stripped out of those urls um that that's really huge and i think
something that a lot of people a lot of bug hunters could benefit from and i also think it's something that
a lot of bug hunter bunk hunters like me rather than enterprise uh appsec people that have a better
understanding of of how these architectures flow um i think people like me overlook this a lot because
we don't understand you know okay this is what the whole flow looks like and this is what people do
in an incident response situation they laugh it off so i don't know it's interesting yeah it's it's
definitely very interesting and i think that architecture side is really valuable like that's one of the big
things that i've learned from like the company sort of like you know engineering side is every company
is very different with how they structure things but a lot of it can be very similar especially just like
the core like aspects of how it's working right like there's some edge proxy that's going to the load
balancer that's going to individual instances of code that is a service right or whatever like and like
that's running some deployment of the thing that an engineer wrote that's a very common
structure like you have services service-based architecture and then you have these routing
and the routing happens one of a handful of ways whether it's through like internal nginx or kubernetes
pods or docker clusters or whatever like you know they have some way of communicating between services and
from the front end to the back end and then there's some you know high performance layer that's handling
the request because large companies i don't think people realize like the scale of requests that
they're dealing with right like large fortune 500 companies are dealing with hundreds of millions
requests uh per hour per minute right like it's it's like lots right if you think about how many
for instance facebook has a 2 billion active daily users or something right like just think about how
many requests like 2 billion people are generating every single you know page load triggers like 10
yeah 15 requests requests on a good day you know it's like right so like from an engineering
architecture perspective there's like there's a huge huge like problem to try and even solve in the
first place and somehow they have this solution that's been architected to like deal with this
massive load of requests and figuring out how that works and like how that's doing that and what path
your request is taking can tell you a lot about the possibilities that you have for lateral movement and
different ways to attack it and like what kinds of characters will and won't pass and um you know
where am i getting stopped at the edge layer or like some middle layer or am i getting stopped at
the back end like where where does this all sort of how does this all connect together you know
authorization at this middle level yeah is there some way a layer right you know exactly that data dude
that would be so interesting to me and i really wish company and maybe there's not like these little
diagrams in your organization or whatever but i imagine there would be for onboarding
um if i got access to those man that would be so awesome you know to to see like okay this
application that i'm working on you know and if it was like actually detailed too because like you'll
often see like all right here's a little cylinder thing and this is the database like three boxes and
it's like external request front end back end you're like what great thanks you know but like if it
was actually detailed like okay coming into this you know nginx this reverse boxing with a proxy pass you
know and it's hitting this and that if it was actually really detailed like that that would be
so helpful and so fascinating and what ends up happening is is when we get at these ssrfs we have
to to figure it out you know and it just it'd be really cool to actually see it one thing i will say
is probably a good place to look for that is engineering blogs okay yeah because a lot of these
companies have engineering blogs that um i hate to break it to you literally nobody reads this i'm really
sorry if somebody listening is like an engineer who's spent like three months writing this really
in-depth engineering blog post for their company this is what i'm talking about pay the freaking
bounties instead of you know like hiring people to write blog posts like i'm just saying like i see
this a lot where like these companies like put this huge in-depth like engineering blog post together
and i'm like who is this for like this is actually for nobody but some like okr at least is nobody's
actually reading that like maybe like you know a handful of people read it and the people think
it's cool think it's really cool but like almost nobody actually sees it however from a bug bounty
perspective it's really really interesting to hear engineers talk about their own internal infrastructure
and how stuff works and how stuff communicates and the problem spaces that they're encountering
and like usually they're very happy to talk about those things in these engineering blogs so
if the company has an engineering blog i would probably go read it because there's
pro tips there's gotta be a there's gotta be a diagram somewhere that's what i'm talking about man
like what kind of big company is gonna win top talent when they say hey um we're not allowing you to go
write a blog right on company time right like like you know if the person really wanted to do that no
they would look like assholes and no one would go work for them right well and from the company's
perspective this is promoting the security brand and like bragging about the capabilities exactly
internally and attracting talent and all that kind of stuff so there is a justification it does
nothing for well but listen nobody reads it right you know maybe your internal people read it and
that's cool and that's great with onboarding if it adds value there then then there's that right
for all i know i'm an anomaly and i'm the one who's not reading it but everybody else does everyone
besides you reads you know these engineering blogs um but but you know but bounty doesn't doesn't
spend three months writing a blog post you know like you just it's such a clear exchange for money
and you're you're rolling the dice in so many different ways why don't you grab onto the one
thing that's for certain you know this is my thought all right any anything else there we want to do you
want to do you want to rebuttal that or should we close it there no no i mean i listen my body is a
really easy way to be like hey we just spent this much money on a vulnerability um balancing that with
the rest of like the finance bs is really difficult but i think it's not as difficult as a lot of a lot
of companies do and the ones who are running vdps because god knows why like you're making more than
five million dollars a year in revenue you should have bug bounty program that pays money
yeah even if it's a small bounty yeah yeah i agree man yeah all right let's wrap it there all right
peace that's fun yeah and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for
listening and if you want more critical thinking content head over to ctbb.show discord join the
discord there's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there and if you want to support
the show there's the discord subscriber tiers which give you access to master classes amas hack alongs
and an exclusive chat channel with us we'll see you there